this issue in philadelphia that bubbled
up on sunday night is going to last for
a lot more than an
hour into the future this is something
that i think the eagles are going to be
dealing with throughout the off season
when we were talking about it yesterday
chris it reminded me of
what the seahawks dealt with for
multiple years after super bowl 49
yeah the the the the consternation in
the building
and the criticism from outside the
building and i think it was a bigger
deal
inside this is both for the eagles so
yesterday the process of trying to dig
out of this hole
continued it was after the game that
doug peterson was asked about
why he put in nate sutfeld he said he
was playing to win the game yesterday he
had a joint press conference with gm
howie roseman and peterson was asked
now that he's had a chance to sleep on
it and understand that people are upset
does he have any more to say about the
way things went down in that game with
jalen hurts being removed
for nate sutfeld here's what peterson
had to say yesterday in response to that
question quite a bit
and um uh you know quite frankly i look
at the entire
body of work i look at the entire season
and it's definitely not the season that
we all had anticipated and
you know our our offensive struggles
have have not been about
you know one one position group or or
one guy or
you know uh whatever it's it's it's it's
been a it's been a
a multi multitude of of issues that
we've had and
and and again last night in that game
you know we were in a situation where we
we
we failed to score as an offense we
failed to score there at the end of the
third quarter we were struggling just a
little bit to move the ball
defensively they kept us kept us in the
game with a couple of takeaways late and
and and my plan was to was to get nate
in the game nate nate's
nate's a guy that that is very capable
of of running our system and executing
in in
an opportunity to to to pull that game
out last night
he said a lot of things nothing he said
was responsive to the question he was
asked other than
i have thought about it other than that
he starts
rambling through all of these other
pastures that have nothing to do with
the question
and i get it because look chris what can
they
say what can they say there's nothing
they can say
and it dawned on me yesterday if all of
these accusations and allegations
they deliberately tried to lose or as
you pointed out yesterday and i think
it's a valid point i mentioned it last
night
on pft the idea that they were trying to
get jalen hurts out of the game before
he had a great win that would make it
harder to put carson wants back on the
field next year
right anything other than we try to win
the game if they're being accused of
this
we tried to lose the game and it's false
they need to be upset
they need to be shouting and yelling and
they need to be in people's faces saying
how dare you suggest
that we would impugn the integrity of
the game with this kind of behavior of
course we wouldn't do that
they're not doing that they're on the
defensive not the offense which tells me
that this is exactly what happened this
is exactly what they were doing
and they have a mess that they're going
to have to clean up even though
i look i understand why i did it too it
makes sense
but in that moment man it's a tough one
to pull off
when you had everyone thinking the
eagles were going to come out and play
that game to win
not play that game to lose and get a
higher draft well and it sounds like
that's where
you know he led his football team to
believe that they were going to play to
win i mean we heard the comments from
jim schwartz
and everything like that about this is a
no hat game they didn't want to see nfc
east division hats
you know champion hats on their on their
field after the game all that
so the players were led to believe that
they were as an organization trying to
win the game
i'm with you mike i mean i understand it
i get
the movement i do you know you just
don't know
again i mean nine and six
all right yeah oh wow you know we beat
washington whoa
whoopty do we're five and eleven we're
five ten and one
oh wait man there's a guy at pick number
seven
that would change our football team man
i wish we didn't win that meaningless
stupid game against washington i
get that i do the risk is what we're
seeing though
we seeing the risk right now crap
the crap has hit the fan there's no
other way to say it we're hearing
players are pissed off
they're reeling he's reeling he didn't
answer the question like you said
he tried to say that they
he made the move to sutfield to like
basically jump start the offense is that
what he was trying to say there that
they didn't score on a drive
well they would have scored if you
kicked the field goals on fourth and
four doug
so obviously i don't know why can't why
can't they just say it
what's what's wrong with just going yes
no
why we all know right now
right we all know it i think they can't
say it for two reasons
okay one is the league office
will descend on them with the same kind
of zeal that we saw the league office
descend on the saints and bounty gate
and the patriots in the various spy
gates and deflategate
the league is not going to do anything
about this
unless someone says oh we were trying to
lose
they're not going to second-guess roster
decisions made
in-game who plays who doesn't they're
not going to do it because they know
it's impossible
to prove anything but if they admit it
then you're done that's number one
that's why they're not going to admit it
because if they admit it the league will
clobber them number two
and this is a a point that i think we
alluded to yesterday
but i don't think i emphasized it enough
and i'm going to write a dedicated post
about this later today on pft
the spread of legalized gambling
complicates this so much because
every bet that's placed is
is done under the premise that the team
is trying to win the game and
your point about jim schwartz that's a
great
pull that's a great point because
when he says this is a no t-shirt no hat
game that sends the message to everyone
we're not laying down we're treating
this as
mini bowl game right this is our exit
for the season
we get a chance to walk off the field
the last game of the regular season
knowing that that team across from us
was playing for everything and we were
playing for nothing and we
kicked their butts schwartz set that
tone
so when you and i picked the eagles we
picked the eagles under the premise that
it was a no t-shirt no hat game
and we thought fair and square 60
minutes the eagles would beat them
so and i was pissed about it and i
didn't have any money on it
right yeah people out there who bet on
the eagles are going to be upset and as
it's legal i see when it's illegal who
are you going to complain to
well you know i got a problem with my
bookie well who cares it's illegal
when it's legal then you start calling
your congressman your senator whoever
then it becomes a bigger deal that's why
the nfl needs to be concerned about what
happens and i don't know what the
solution is no
but that's why the nfl needs to be
concerned well yeah gamblers you better
just not bet on these type of games i
mean that's
that's you know that that would be my
advice to them that's just any time
there's this there's this there's the
threat of this happening
uh why can't the eagles come out
and just say something as in hey we were
trying to win the game but in the
process
we we needed to evaluate players for
2021.
you know that's another way i just go
ahead what
well you say that last week and and in
hindsight you know
peterson kind of hinted around that nate
sutfeld may play
but he didn't he wasn't that that
express about it my point is
that's a seed you need to plant before
the game yeah not after the game yeah if
you say it before the game
instead of this is a no hat no t-shirt
game
okay after the game it's it's a it's a
tougher sell
because it's something you should have
made clear before the game started yeah
okay i
i get that you're right it is a tougher
sell there's no doubt about it
listen they're they're in a tough spot
here there's no doubt they're gonna have
to deal with this
for probably a few days hearing this but
all in all
it still goes back to they thought this
was the right thing for their
organization
now we're gonna see how it plays out i
don't think we're gonna know if this is
the right thing for their organization
right now let's see what happens in the
draft
and let's see what the backlash
continues to be from their football team
doug peterson the one thing he he's been
phenomenal
at managing players and personalities in
his football team
with the philadelphia eagles and i got
to think
that he welcomed this in
in some ways just because of he's got to
have confidence in himself
that he could talk to the guys the right
way in the locker room
and smooth this over but if guys feel
like they were lied to or you know
or bs to some degree last week in
preparation for the game
that's going to be a deeper wound and
there's going to have to be some healing
there and so maybe some more
heart-to-heart type of talks that
yeah to repair the locker room a little
bit might have to happen
i remember when peterson got the job
jeffrey lurie touted this concept of
emotional intelligence and it caused me
and maybe others to just assume that
doug peterson was this bengali that was
always going to say the right thing and
do the right thing
and have the right relationships but the
evidence is there
that that maybe he's not based upon how
this
was handled based upon these reports
that carson wentz thinks their
relationship is fractured beyond repair
and and we're going to talk about wentz
skipping out on talking to the media
yesterday which may
kind of lend some credence to the idea
that he's upset with doug peterson and
peterson
hasn't handled it it could just be that
chip kelly set the bar so damn low for
emotional intelligence in philadelphia
that anyone would have more than chip
kelly had when it relates to dealing
with players and media and everyone else
but uh yeah i think there are real
questions about people skills and about
understanding
what you need to say to your players and
when and how
because they failed this was this was a
huge
unexpected pass fail test chris and they
failed it they did
i mean to this point they definitely did
fail it
now we'll see in the off season you know
the roster what guys start to say how
the draft unfolds
you know what's philadelphia gonna say
and the fans and some of the players say
if
you know okay the draft comes around and
they get some stud at number six
where everybody's excited that might
lessen the blow too so i think this is
something that's gonna
kind of resonate here throughout the
spring and everything
like that we'll see you know how the
eagles can handle it
best going forward the best they could
do going forward
is trade the sixth pick for the ninth
pick and get some huge haul so then they
can say look at what we got
look at what we got right for for losing
that game will you please leave us alone
now please please please but i don't
think that's going to happen because
they're probably going to drive
too hard of a bargain if whoever has the
ninth pick wants the sixth pick
depending upon who's available in that
spot
um there was the report last night from
jeff mclean of the philadelphia inquiry
kind of alluded to it that there were
there were problems on the sideline
during the game multiple defensive
players
wanted to confront doug peterson and
were prevented from doing so
jason kelsey and another offensive
player actually went to peterson during
the game
with kind of a what gives uh explanation
which
which underscores your point chris he
didn't
set this up internally he led them to
believe
that they were going to go out there and
they were going to try to beat
washington and you know in everything he
said and everything he did in the week
of preparation that's the message that
they got
whether it was what he said before the
game in the locker room what he said at
halftime
all of a sudden it flips it just tells
me that it was handled
so poorly that these players didn't see
it coming that we didn't see it coming
that no one saw it coming
that that exacerbates the problem yeah
and uh
uh the report in the inquirer shows that
he's got issues
outside and inside that he's gonna have
to deal with definitely
and i think what makes it worse because
yeah you know like you just pointed out
it sounds like there was no warning
to the players during the week what
makes it worse
for the players at least right from that
standpoint is
they were on the field putting their
butts on the line throwing their bodies
around
and this is where it really hurts
they were out there going we can beat
this team
we're every bit as good we're better we
can win
and they were out playing washington i
mean they really were
in a lot of ways to where yeah that was
scary
so that will piss off players even more
because they're sitting there going wait
we got we can beat them
yeah i know they're going to the
playoffs but i'm blocking them i'm
feeling it out here
we have the energy in the team to beat
them today on this given night
and then to have that kind of just bam
knife in the tire deflation like
what we're putting nate sudfeld out
there you know that
that's the killer and that's probably
where jason kelsey's like what
gives dude you know i just pulled and
had to smash my head
into chase young 12 times now you're
gonna tell me we're not really playing
and that is the problem and that's where
he's gonna have to have some tremendous
people skills uh to figure this one out
ron rivera coach of the washington
football team addressed the issue
yesterday in the aftermath of winning
the game and in turn winning the nfc
east here's what rivera had to say
you play who's out there i'm not going
to apologize for winning apparently
that's what everybody wants me to do is
apologize for when i'm not going to
because you play the game as it's set up
okay
nobody complained when pittsburgh did
what they did last night
against cleveland i mean come on this
this is just the way it is
okay we got in the playoffs we're seven
and nine
okay i've been in seven eight one in the
playoffs i was on an eight and eighteen
it was in the playoffs
and you don't apologize for getting into
the playoffs okay
you apologize for losing in the playoffs
at least i believe you do
but you don't apologize for getting in
because it's it's been a hard roll
for us and and nobody seems to care
about that nobody cared two weeks ago
when we didn't have our best
some of our best players nobody cared
last week when we didn't have them so
why should we be concerned if a coach
decides to do something he thinks is
best for his team
okay that's the thing i think people
need to understand this is just the way
the game's played this is just the way
things happen
a lot of people are happy about it a lot
of people aren't happy about it
and that's just tough that's just the
way it is okay
i mean so many things have happened in
this world that are tough that are hard
okay this is just the game that we're
playing and we're going to play the game
as it comes to us and i'm not going to
apologize i'm not that's just the way it
is
i like i like feisty ron rivera
but there is a fundamental difference
between strategically resting starters
in advance of the postseason versus
strategically removing starters in the
hopes of losing so you get a higher
draft pick or
as the case may be removing jalen hurts
before he does something that will make
it impossible to go back to carson wentz
next year which is also
a potential explanation there's a chance
it's both reasons yeah i think so it
happened right
but but there is a there is a difference
so and and that's kind of what bothers
me about some of the the things that
we're hearing in response don't compare
it
to removing starters when you've
clinched the one seed or you've decided
we're probably not going to get the two
seed buffalo's going to beat miami so
we're not going to put ben
roethlisberger out there we're going to
give him the week off
to get him ready for the playoffs that
is fundamentally different than choosing
to lay down
and lose the game for strategic reasons
unrelated to this year
these are issues of what's best for my
team next year
yeah uh and and look here here's the
thing
i it's it shouldn't be taboo
the fact that the nfl has traditionally
said oh nobody tanks we don't see
evidence of that everybody tries to win
every single game
the fact that they have pushed that for
so long and ignored the tanking that can
happen that is in plain sight
the temptation is there as long as you
let the worst team have the first pick
in the draft
and fill out the rest of the first round
based upon worst all the way to super
bowl winner
you're going to have that temptation but
they they they
want to act like it's not there it's
there and they act like it doesn't exist
so when it happens people are stunned i
i
was texting with my niece the huge
browns fan yesterday
she was oblivious to all these issues
and motivations most fans are
yeah right because because they act like
it's not part of the strategy
but it is for some teams and we saw that
sunday night it's going to continue
to be more of a strategy the day of
analytics and all of those things and
you know again more knowledge about
assets and trades and things like that
you know the fact that there's a salary
cap with first round picks and all of
that there is
more easily moved assets too at this
point
that i would think we're going to
continue to see more and more of this
type of play
you know again we know it's risky yes
the biggest reason we're talking about
it though is like
kind of just what you just said that
proves it we're talking about it because
it's
never been thrown in everybody's face
the way it was sunday night
where you're going wait this team looks
like they're gonna pull off the
upset what wait this is national tv
this is a playoff caliber game there's
another team at home that is
depending on a team to get in the
playoffs wait they're
they're taking a the quarterback out
who's been successful lately and putting
a guy in that
we've never seen before and doesn't even
look right out there on the football
field wait that doesn't seem right and i
think that's where it's just blown up
because like you said it's the first
time the really
you know i don't want to you know for
lack of a better way low level
just part-time pay attention to the nfl
has had to smack them in the face and
it's it's taken you know sports media by
storm here the last 24 hours
and i think that's right the casual fan
the super bowl sunday fan the late
season fan the did my team make it to
the playoffs that's all i care about
fan is like what wait a minute why is
everybody upset what's going on here why
aren't the giants in the playoffs what
did the eagles do
and when they start getting answers to
those questions they're like well i
don't agree with that and
and that's what's adding to this
becoming a bigger deal than maybe
anyone thought it was going to be as it
was happening on sunday night
we had some feisty ron rivera we also
have
another coach in the nfc east who is not
happy with what happened and it's
aftermath now rivera is happy with what
happened
he's not happy with the aftermath judge
isn't happy with what happened and he's
part of the aftermath here's joe
judge the giants coach with his thoughts
on what the eagles did on sunday night
obviously players have asked me
throughout the day and i just can't
express that
i think one thing to keep in mind with
this season is
we had a lot of people opt in to this
season
okay we a lot of people opt in all right
coaches players
that includes family members as well
alright so
to look at a group of grown men who i
asked to give me effort on a day in day
out basis
and empty the tank and then i can look
them in the eye insure them that i'm
always going to do everything i can to
put them at a competitive advantage
and play them in a position of strength
to me you don't ever want to disrespect
those players in our effort and
disrespect the game
the sacrifices that they made to come
into work every day and test before
coming in
to sit in meetings spaced out to wear
masks to have shields over those masks
to go through extensive protocols to
travel in unconventional ways
to get text messages at 6 30 in the
morning practice is going to be canceled
we have to do a virtual day okay to tell
them please don't have your family here
for thanksgiving
please avoid christmas gatherings we
know it's your wife's birthday
let's make sure we put that one off to
the off season
there's a number of sacrifices been made
by all the players and coaches in this
league
there's a number of sacrifices that come
along as well with the family members
the people connected to them
to disrespect the effort that everyone
put forward to make this season a
success for the national football league
to disrespect the game by going out
there not competing for 60 minutes and
doing everything you can to help those
players win
we will never do that as long as i'm the
head coach of new york giants
you know a lot of people were motivated
and inspired and driven by what judge
had to say there's some logical flaws in
there
and i don't want to quibble too much
with it the idea that we had people opt
in to play the season that was to play
the season that wasn't to determine who
gets
the privilege of the 32 teams to play in
the postseason
they worked hard to get the games in so
people could
earn their money and pursue their
livelihood
this wasn't well everyone opted in so we
have this this stronger duty to the
integrity of the game i think he goes a
little too far with that okay but i can
understand why he's upset
i understand why he's upset he should be
upset um
but at the same time he should
understand that there may be
a chance at some point down the road if
the giants on his watch are
three and 12 going into week 17 and john
mara comes to him and says
i think we'd like to see what the backup
quarterback can do this weekend if you
know what i mean i mean that's always
there and
that's my other point too chris and i'll
let you chime in if he truly is upset
about it
he shouldn't be talking to the media he
should be going to john mara one of the
most influential owners in the nfl and
saying hey john
you should do something about this
you've got the hotline
to the commissioner like like uh like
they had at the batman back in the day
the red phone and you pull the the head
of the statue up you pick up the phone
whatever they did they press the button
the bat signal all that stuff
you can go to the commissioner and you
can say this is unacceptable do
something about it
so i i don't i don't think that john
merrill will because again i think the
league is just kind of like we don't we
don't want to get our hands dirty with
this we don't want to dignify this we
just rather it all go away yeah i mean i
i think so
and because it's a tough spot what is
the league really gonna do here
in this spot like you said there's
there's really a no-win situation
to shed more light on it it's only gonna
bring it into people's
you know their their their site anyways
as far as like
oh this does go on wow i didn't know it
happened then and it happened here
so there the nfl wants nothing to do
with this
you know the big thing is hey the
eagles did what was they felt was best
for their organization
you could never fault them for that okay
but what joe judge does do i mean first
off i mean you're right
you know the kova thing sure it is a
more
of a of a tough year and i feel like you
want to respect players a little bit
more because of all the things they've
had to
go through but that doesn't have
anything to do with this conversation
but i think the number one thing joe
judge shows right there
is everything we've talked about that
is what that's why you have talked to
long time
nfl people who go this is why this is a
dicey
scary situation to involve into the
culture of your football team
for the philadelphia eagles and that's
why i think a lot of big time coaches
never did these type of things because
they don't want that
ever to be infused into their locker
room or have their players think whoa
my coach bs me or lied to me what else
is he lying about and all of those type
of things
and then again the coaches are the ones
that are always we compete in meetings
we compete in practice we compete all
day long we gotta lay it on the line
that's how we're gonna differentiate
ourselves so in this close league
is we're gonna compete at everything and
then
well no that doesn't happen in week 17.
so joe judge at least gave you i think a
great look and do like
hey this is why you don't do it and this
is the message he wants to send to his
team and doug peterson is going to have
to clean up his message to his team
we need someone other than joe judge to
carry that you're right
because joe judge obviously is
personally most interested in it mike
mccarthy would be good to point play
that flight because like hey
we went out there and busted our butts
winning a game thinking that we had a
chance to maybe get to the playoffs if
we won that game if we'd have known
well why why did we try to win why did
we go all out
to try to keep our hopes alive for the
postseason
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports